welcome to the edge
of your one and only the lion
as in me Micah Parsons linebacker
defensive end or Mr everywhere and some
people say the hungry lion where we're
coming to you live every Monday and
we're going to talk about you know the
hottest takes and obviously there's
nothing more hot right now than our big
win over the Giants now some of you may
say
the Giants are bad the Giants are not
good and you know obviously hating
Dallas Cowboys takes but this is a
playoff team this is a team that knocked
off your number two seed Vikings a team
that added speed Deft uh number one
receiver
I mean number one tight end
Darren Waller you still bring back your
franchise running back saquon Barkley
and you signed your franchise
quarterback Daniel Jones this off season
so big moves by the Giants
so some people may say
is the Cowboys the real deal or the
Giants just bad well I look at the
playoff team that added a lot of weapons
you know so how can that team be bad
you know that that just makes no sense
to me I just think people just want to
take away the dominance like if a boxer
goes into the ring and he dominates a
fighter do we make excuses oh the
fighter wasn't ready or the poor person
is just more prepared more ready and
I'll execute that's the other fighter
three biggest takeaways from the night
obviously the turnovers and our d-line
was going to get after we said this off
season that we're gonna be the most
defensive team in the NFL the most
dominant defensive team in the NFL and
be the number one defense that's where
we set the standard from all 22 to 26
guys in our defensive room
and now we take that personally I think
last year when we came off that field
in the bay we just felt that hurt that
urge to really show people why we the
best a lot of people talked about us but
I think if we take away their threes and
they just don't score we win that
football game and uh we let it show and
pour out on that field Sunday night
number two takeaway
we have a chance to have the most
dominant defensive line I think the
league have seen in a long time
I know I know I know
but if we learn to keep gelling keep
getting better week and weekend out oh
man oh man Cowboys Nation you Bears
better buckle up and get ready because
this is going to the Super Bowl
and number three Daniel Jones is not a
bad quarterback
I know I know I know
some of you may think that he is a bad
quarterback and why ReSound him you have
to remember
David Jones just went against
top three defensive
uh teams in the league
um they're still learning Joe together
they're still he he's still learning how
to be the guy it's only his second year
we're buying the ball so he gives he
gives Grace I think I don't think I
think nowadays we don't give the same
Grace as we do with guys like Peyton
Manning when they came into the league
you know we don't give guys that he'll
he'll eventually get it Eli Manning we
don't give them the same Grace
as we do guys like Daniel Jones who may
click a little bit later everyone
doesn't click at the same time Kurt
Warner you know a guy who clicked way
later in his career we don't give them
the same Grace and those guys all turned
out to be Hall of Famers so it's so easy
to say oh this guy is bad in the moment
because that's just what US people do us
as fans who love football and the guy
that we're rooting for isn't doing well
like oh it's just bad but the reality is
he had some really good player he's a
National Football League he was a first
round pick he's just a guy that's going
to take a little bit transition
but let's cue in on some top plays that
came into the game and we're going to
look at this double team that I created
for my God Osa to get a sack and talk
about the presence of being on the field
the mindset it takes to keep going no
matter what's in front of you and uh
just being dominant as you can be
letting your heart pour out for the
nation as you can see I'm coming off
from ripping Thomas is helping to Guard
the guard knows he can't touch me
one-on-one he just he just can't it's
just like uh
and it leads for my guy also to come up
and under it's just so easy so clean
something we rep so much ripping up Phil
fighting fighting the tackle fighting
back to the quarterback and uh it was a
great natural rush and to be honest with
you I wasn't even supposed to do that
that play I had something with d-law but
I wanted my guy also to eat a little bit
more I guess
and you know
they say
the Rivalry
Chinese Cowboys will forever be a
rivalry even though it has been a
landslide with deck 11 straight wins
don't let that go to unnoticed
it's just
it's just something to write when you
got both got them blues on the field and
you buckle up on Sunday Night Football
it's just nothing like it and you know
this driver goes way back way back way
back it'll always be a division rival
everyone
tends to
you know
everyone tends to just jump out of
shorts when things don't go right you
know what I'm saying so let's not say
this is an arrival this will always be a
rivalry because the moment that they
start streaking
then they'll say oh the Cowboys are down
bad this is a robbery it's just always
going to be back and forth so I always
like to just keep it plain and neutral
it's always going to be a rivalry and
when they come see us in November
they're going to play their hearts out
again it's going to be some revenge on
their minds and it's something that we
can't go we can't sleep on this this
game was significant a statement that
we're trying to make to be Super Bowl
champs and we kind of March our one step
up the mountain
but in terms of where we're trying to go
but we cannot let this game get to our
head
we got Aaron Rodgers next week and my
mind is already starting to click for
him I'm seeing Aaron Rodgers in my head
I'm twirling I'm going crazy right now
I'm just my mind's going a little loose
right now guys be careful with me
um as an offense
I think I can challenge the Cowboys
defense offense I can challenge the
Cowboys defense
um to be honest with you I saw the 49ers
the 49ers Steelers game
um
and it's gonna bring me to my next point
the 49ers looked extremely good
Christian McCaffrey Brandon and I you
look like he's about to make a huge jump
um obviously this is his contract here
um they look special man I think Purdy
looked really really good Christian
looked as good as he always do
and uh I always think that's just a good
matchup every time we go against the
49ers it's just head-to-head hardcore
physical matchup and it's always it's
always a fun one and you know obviously
if you guys saw the Miami and the
Chargers game they might we're going to
play Miami this year obviously when you
got the two fastest receivers in the
league it's always going to bring
problems you know speed does matter in
this league we're going against Josh
Allen it's gonna be fun watching the
Bills versus Jets tonight
um it's going to be it's gonna be a test
run that we played them near Christmas
time
um but I those are some teams that I
think
can potentially push us to the Limit and
I'm not discrediting it because we
played it just next week uh I didn't get
this really good chance to see them so I
might recant this statement
but uh it's gonna be a fun matchup to
see what happens tonight you know
and
uh this off season I did a lot of work
to get where I am right now uh I hope a
lot of people saw the work that I was
trying to put in put in the work with
guys like Andrew Whitworth uh putting a
guy at work with my guy Lance Dean
um you know my guy Tony Mack with boxing
and you know trying to really be
prepared to go to deep Waters to take
this team to another level and challenge
the guys around me
um because some leaders I wouldn't say
I'm a vocal leader I just believe that
some people leave by how they play how
they act decisions behaviors choices and
actions
um not just about the words that they
speak so for me I wanted to come in the
most fantastic shape I wanted to push my
teammates to the Limit I wanted to show
them that the line is here and I'm not
here to play games I'm here to hunt I'm
here to kill I'm here to win
championships and uh you know I just
adapted that mindset like hey come on
now let's get it before we go around a
league I wanna make sure some players
get the love that they deserve Aaron
Jones my brother oh my God
you said it Jordan and Jordan love
I mean there's a lot of preseason hype
about the Chicago Bears and I'm still
riding with the Chicago Bears I think
Justin fields and DJ Moore getting each
other was extremely important extremely
important I think they will develop to
keep learning and keep growing but man
oh man that Aaron Jones Come to play and
Jordan love oh my gosh like oh my gosh
Aaron Jones three touchdowns are we for
real like man oh man and something that
no one realized in that game
and besides uh TJ Watt uh in the 49ers
and the Steelers game TJ watt had three
sacks but a guy that no one's talking
about is Drake Jackson he had three
sacks why isn't no one talking about
Drake Jackson
ah we talking about pass rushes it's
always good to talk about me and all the
other prolific guys Max Crosby but guys
don't let these guys get in you know
because it goes back to last year Alex
High Smith I like Smiley Smith had 15
sex I think and no one talked about him
he was he held it down while TJ watt was
out for injury and he dominant he got
extended but no one talks about Alex
Heisman I thought he had a great
guarantee he was a dominant pass rusher
last year so don't let these guys that
um
you know get thrown under that sunlight
because he surrounded guys like Nick
Bosa and Fred Warner
and guys like that because they're
loaded with such a great team I think
he's a person I'm gonna have to look out
for
huh
I'ma obviously give a big shout to the
Cowboys defense line man I love my
brothers we did what we supposed to do
and then tour man tour oh man you got us
a little sugar on here in Cowboys
country where you look brother uh that
bounce back of yours is looking
tremendous keep proving the people wrong
I love a fight story I love people who
never give up you ain't giving up man
and it showed all these critics said
this that and the other and you just you
just shoved it down their throat man
congratulations hell of a game I believe
we had a clip of tour acting surprised
when he had 466 yards like he didn't
even believe how good of a game he had
and I always think those are the best
games because that means you just so
long through the air for you today three
touchdowns Tyree kill 466 yards for you
today unbelievable day yeah 466 through
the air for you today three touchdowns
Tyree kill four
brothers
the first game in the season isn't met a
statement to the league and guess what
we are awoke we will see what you're
capable of we are not we are not
underestimating you brother no more no
more
um and my Edge player of the week
man this is hard but you know TJ while I
was seeing Drake Jackson had great games
TJ watt had a terrific game like you
know amazing game uh Trayvon Diggs had
two Force front moves he was kind of me
all day about it hurt my feelings you
know we got our usual bed and obviously
he out played the line last week so we
gotta go out there and hunt next week
but uh you know we gotta give it to TJ
watt man two Force for almost three
sacks terrific game kept fighting even
though they were getting
uh uh I would say you know
they were they were I don't think no one
expected that type of game especially
how you know Kenny Pickett and them look
during preseason they look clean they
look good I don't think no one expected
to Landslide win like that but uh he
kept going and I thought you know he was
just uh a Traverse player last week
but what kind of burn with that was Pat
Pete tells the offense that Purdy has
tails and then Purdy goes and throws two
TDS on Pat you know it it kind of
reminds me with Jamar Chase with the
elves you know sometimes as competitors
we think we know something we we tend to
jump out the boots jump on something and
sometimes it just turns the brightness
you know that's the thing about
compositions you never know how things
are going to work you never know it's
the irony of the game uh football has
its own Karma and it's called that good
old good old a butt kicking on the field
and that's what happened to both of them
teams who said that
and I just don't think
that we should sleep on Brock Purdy no
more yes he was a seventh round pick yes
he came in late in the season and won
six straight Games took him to the NFC
championship before his injury
but Purdy you would not be slept on no
more brother I think people are coming
for you the same way they come for
Rogers Patrick Mahomes yes you are
surrounded by a great team but you are
playing your butt off and uh you got one
hell of a story brother
um if we were to rank Purdy right now I
would put Purdy around
I think Purdy's the top 15 quarterback
there's things that we still want to see
from Purdy not when Purdy's winning but
when Purdy's down you know I think the
adversity aspect of the football game is
huge learning how to play from behind
learning situational football
um it's not something I'm saying he
can't do it's just something that we
just haven't seen yet
and you know
um and then if we still talking about
the 49ers
you know obviously congratulations to
Nick Bosa on that huge mega million
dollar contract with a set a statement
for what dply should get man come be
more excited for Nick Bosa and I keep
telling people it's not about the
contract it's about what he did last
year what he accomplished
um and that's the significance he went
out there and showed he was the best
defensive player and he got paid as the
best defensive player and we couldn't be
more happy for Nick Bosa and I I see a
lot of people are saying what does this
mean for me I am not Nick Bosa I am not
Nick boss's shoes I gotta go out there
and earn my own right to say I'm the
best defensive player in the league
um and some may say I am but the
humility in me and the fact is I have
not won a defensive player of the year
yet I have not been named the top
defensive player in the league yet by my
peers so it's something I'm gonna have
to go earn yes I am talented I am hungry
enough to go get it but the fact is I
gotta go get it myself so
therefore this means nothing Nick Bros
contract I gotta go out there and earn
that right and hopefully follow suit one
day to be on Nick Bose's level and reach
that that
tear that he has reached
and you know after seeing the 49ers in
the NFC
I think my top two threats are in the
NFC are the 49ers the Philadelphia
Eagles and Dallas Cowboys
that's the top three threats in the NFC
Dallas Cowboys is number one threat okay
and then I'm gonna have to go with the
49ers they're the NFC champions okay
they were the NFC championship
if it's a big if we don't know what
would have happened if Brock Purdy or
the backup quarterback got hurt we we
truly don't know what would have
happened okay
um
because the 49ers started off I mean the
Eagles start off so hot so it's hard to
just say that
it just was based off of Brooke I uh
part of me don't believe because the
also the Eagles the 49ers struggled to
get stops okay but
I don't think that you know it would
have cost too much of a difference man
the Eagles were too talented last year
too strong and I mean they're Elite but
that 49ers team got the same team back I
I believe the chemistry is out the roof
they added Javon Hargrave you know a big
interior Russia where Nick both said
Eric harmstead and that guy that
everyone's sleeping on right now Drake
Jackson
um it's just something that you know we
just have to we we we we have to
consider them in the way that they you
know scored on the top tier Steelers
defense I think the Steelers are known
for their defense and what they do and
uh coach Tomlin
um they they diced them up and uh they
they played a terrific game so we can't
let that go unnoticed okay and then the
Philadelphia Eagles obviously don't
bring it back James Bradberry big slave
they went got Jayla Carter they still
got Fletcher Cox they still got Hassan
ready they still have uh Joshua and
Jordan Davis I mean you could go on and
on Nolan Smith I mean that defense is
loaded obviously with the premier
offensive line they got what Lane
Johnson and they got you know AJ Brown
and Devonte Smith who can both be number
one receivers on any team and you know
obviously another highly new rich guy
Jalen Hurst who just got pace and you
make him out to be a top 10 quarterback
I mean these teams are just loaded uh
with talent I think the sky's the limit
for every team you know we all play each
other this year so it's going to be
extremely exciting to see
um I think every every game this year is
going to be
a battle it's going to be a battle you
know it's going to be a testament it's
going to be it's going to come down to
the wire and it's going to be a super
exciting to watch but those those is the
top three teams I don't think you could
play any other team uh close to it the
Vikings lost to the Bucks the football
team should have dominated the Cardinals
without Kyler Murray
um I thought that game was way too close
uh for what they said they could be and
where they're at I I thought that could
be in a way better game a way clearer
game
um but you know those are just my takes
you know at the end it doesn't matter we
still got to go out there and execute
but those are right now the top three
teams in the NFC
okay
and you know speaking of big money did
y'all watch Joe burrow and the Bengals
lose to the Browns 24-3 okay all right
so let's talk about this everyone is
throwing
shade on Joe burrow
um they're saying well you know they
like to count as money just sign a huge
contract once again Joe burrow you know
you're my guy congratulations way to get
paid brother
um you deserve everything in the world
um and we're not going to sit here and
take that away from me listen
everyone has his days it's a National
Football League I keep telling us the
best league in the world okay like some
days people are gonna out-execute you
you know there was rain there was but
there's no excuses at the day
then he had a job to do and it was to go
out there and be the best and that day
he wasn't his best there's no excuse for
that but all we're going to say is Joe
Bro back or is Cleveland a real deal
um I think Cleveland has always been
loaded with Talent always but now that
you add to Sean Watson in the roster now
do we say Cleveland's a legitimate team
um you make Cleveland a clean team with
the talent they already have I mean now
we're seeing the Sky Zone I mean with
those young Corners Denzel Ward Greg
Newsom uh the young rookie
from last year uh what's his name uh
Martin some mer some uh we forget but
you know they they're DB and then you
still got Grand Dell pick I mean their
DB course loaded and you got uh a
woozian uh man bro they're they're
they're linebacker their first seven
obviously with Miles Garrett uh Mark
Emerson that's the DB Martin Emerson and
then you got that young you got their
front miles Garrett they added to Darius
Smith I mean can we be for real guys
Cleveland might be the real deal we
can't sit here and act like Cleveland is
not serious bro like Cleveland has a
chance to be a really really good team
people are saying they look at where
they were before you know before I got
to the Cowboys we were top 10 draft pick
team and now we had last last two years
we've been a 12-win team so you can't
look at a team about their history you
can only look at a team about where
they're at now and where they can be and
what's their potential and I think
Cleveland has the potential to be a
playoff team they can have a chance to
go make a Deep Run as they continue to
stay disciplined continue to stay
dominant and obviously their new
defensive coordinator had a hell of a
game to slow down Joe burrow and
obviously I would say the three-headed
dragon with Jamar Chase Tyler Boyd and T
Higgins I mean that's what you can call
it the 300 Dragon because he has
obviously if not the best receiving
corpse in the National Football League
guys and that's just the truth about it
so Cleveland is the real deal
when the Bengals poor job in the fourth
quarter is that benching no it is not
benching okay you got your franchise
quarterback who just got paid who came
off a calf injury and Camp so barely
really got to work with his guys the
Cameron Street and timing could be off
so guys be realistic is is Joe Bro bad
no he just had a bad day off night he
wasn't able to build that relationship
back with his guys and uh you know it
tended to cost him and it's not benching
it's called protecting your guy you know
something I thought the Giants should
have done I don't think Jay Jones should
have been in that game in the fourth
quarter I thought they should have
protected him and pulled him out and
barring injury their season will be over
without Daniel Jones the Bengals did the
smart decision by pulling Joe Bro saying
hey we we we're going to submit we're
going to take our loss and we're going
to move on to next week and get better
that's the best thing you can do I do
not agree with Daniel Jones standing out
there into that last drive that was I
thought that was wrong I thought it was
deceiving that's your franchise
quarterback and he's got there with the
backup offensive line still getting
sacked and hit I I just don't understand
maybe it was a you know proven Moment by
the Giants I have no idea a Learning
lesson who knows but I thought Daniel
Jones should have got pulled out so it
technically is not Vincent
my teams that are over hyped right now
and my opinion are
overhyped it's hard to say teams are
overhyped obviously with the injuries
um going around across the league
um people would say the Giants were
overhyped they thought the Giants would
be super good and I think the Giants
still are a good team I just think I
don't really think there's a lot of
teams that's over hyped it's about
what players are the best and who's
going to outplay you know at the end of
the day I think that's what it's about I
I might just continue to say the NFL is
the best league in the world and if you
got the best players in the world you're
going to have a better outcome of the
game you got your your players is going
to dictate the game I mean just just
look at what Tyreke Hill was able to do
over 200 yards like are we serious like
for gay I it's cold-blooded I mean like
are we going to say Tyra kills not a top
three player you put Tyreek Hill on any
team in the National Football League
your team changes I mean we just have to
be serious about these moments about
who's on what team and and has access to
who this is just about who's getting in
the bar obviously he's proving it
doesn't matter who's throwing him the
ball whether it's tour or the best
quarterback in the National Football
League Patrick Mahomes
Tyreek Hill is Tyreek Hill it doesn't
matter you know and that just goes that
just grows across and uh
and and it turns out to bite them when
they go down to Detroit and you know
they lose down to Detroit they lose to
Detroit and Arrowhead at home and they
also didn't have their best defensive
tackle Chris Jones and you think about
that you think about Chris Jones if
Chris Jones is in that game do you think
Chris Jones
changes that game absolutely there's no
way Chris Jones doesn't make an impact
play or make uh an advantage in that
game where it puts in the chief's favor
and y'all say well why was Chris Jones
at the game
Chris Jones loves his team those are his
brothers people have so much to say
about oh he wants more money she gets
paid we can't count Chris Jones's
Pockets Chris Jones is Chris Jones no
one can be Chris Jones okay
Chris Jones deserves whatever he could
get another man's money is not no one
else's business okay we should never get
into anyone's business you know the
whole out that's that's all his
decisions and his financials we know
Chris Jones is if not one of the top
three if not the best defensive tackle
in the league right now competing with
Aaron Donald uh Jeffrey Simmons
um Grady J anybody you want to put in
your top three he's up there and uh he's
for sure locked into that top three
there there's no if ends or buts about
his Divas out he had over 15 sacks last
year and he's looking they get more
money what do I say Chief cepel you know
if Dallas Cowboys had a chance to play
Chris Jones we better pay Chris Jones
you know he's just that good he's that
type of talent I think we should talk
about some of these rookies right now I
think you know it's interesting to see
the rookie class uh turn out to who they
are going to be
um but the guy that stands out are like
the guy that ever is talking about is
Bijan Robinson I think Bijan has a
chance
to be obviously offensive Rookie of the
Year
people can ask me are you surprised no
I'm not surprised at all Bijan showed
this in college
I'm not surprised at all Bijan is that
guy he will forever be that guy I think
they need to find ways to find him
find ways for bija to get more carries
more love I think
that they also need to find ways for
Kyle Pitts to get more love I mean just
look at it so
Falcons have to do better with them but
I think Bishop is going to be that guy
I'm excited to see what he does the rest
of the year I think this guy's a limit
for Bijan he's just showing a glimpse of
what he can do and we are excited about
it Bijan keep going brother keep going
everybody's talking about Tom Brady
returning to Gillette Stadium this
weekend
uh he was back in his Pages Jersey but
just so you guys know Tom Brady owes me
a jersey okay I feel like
[Music]
his last time on the field uh to send
him home and uh is there something and
we you know obviously y'all saw us hang
out in all season you know Tom is cool
you know and all that and he told me I
was going to get a jersey I told yo
where's my jersey like I'm looking for
my jersey now don't just tell me that we
get a jersey did not get my jersey time
time I'm looking at you right now if you
see this give me my jersey time send my
jersey I'm gonna put you right there I'm
gonna put you right there Tom send me my
jersey before I have to go hurt you
again Tom I don't want to hurt you I
don't have to look for you I don't want
to you know start growling and run for
your time bring me my jersey you drop it
off you could DM me for my address you
can get it right now Tom don't dump me
don't more time you owe me I don't care
how many times I hit you because my
rookie year you tried to embarrass me
number one do all the bad boys so guess
what time I was just looking for some
veggies brother and I need my jersey
before I start looking for some more
Avengers brother so hurry up
I did I think something that surprised
me the most uh in Sunday football was
the Seahawks I thought the Seahawks was
going to come in obviously added Jackson
Smith and jigba uh with responding Judo
Smith will be way more dominant you know
and uh we played the Seahawks this year
so not me not give them no bulletin
material I just didn't think they came
out to play and uh it looked a little
dirty a little chippy uh I think as a in
the football league it's a Brotherhood
okay I don't think no one should do
anything dirty we shouldn't be trying to
hit each other hurt each other
um so that extra stuff after the play
you know what I'm talking about let's
cut that out bro like and then it's a
football game if you're getting beat up
you're not the game's not that's not
that's not so-and-so's fault let's just
keep it clean
um you know but the Rams I mean the Rams
with Matthew Stafford back in that
quarterback they look legit and they did
it without Cooper cup I and a lot of
young guys on their defense I mean they
just beat a playoff team like that is a
huge win in the direction that the Rams
were hoping to go I think Sean McVay you
know obviously being
um
you know as great as he is of a coach
you know
he showed that he could bring any team
around and I think he's doing that and I
just think a funny moment in the game
was when we saw Geno Smith yeah oh my
God when he saw Aaron Donald coming and
I mean and I was the best defensive
forever
[Applause]
Pusher comes late and it's incomplete
without me I might scream oh my God too
like he's just that good I mean we're
talking about the Hall of Famer the
epitome of the best defensive tackle to
ever play in the game maybe even the
best defensive player depending how you
want to argue I mean this guy is legit I
mean he's dominated for so long
obviously Judo has nightmares about
Aaron Donald that he's screaming oh my
God like he's coming out his Dreams and
Nightmares and we are not in Philly oh
my God so Aaron Donald great job Gino do
not let Aaron Donald haunt you no more
you see him one more time this year you
must crush him Geno get your lick back
you have to you have to
um
before we look ahead to week two
uh my three most impressive teams in
week one uh outside of the Cowboys like
I said was the Rams knocking off a
playoff team
um and then I would say the Bucks uh is
Baker Mayfield making a comeback uh
holding off the the playoff number two
team and the NFC the Vikings like we
can't Overlook these things and like
Baker Baker Mayfield he looked good he
looked good he didn't look great he
looked good I think he looked good
enough to be a playoff team potentially
potentially
so I think they were super impressive uh
and another team I would say that uh
impress me is a Cleveland Browns I don't
think no one expected Cleveland to win
everyone wrote Cleveland off because
obviously Joe burrow in the three-headed
dragon we talked about it but like I
said with the talent they have we cannot
underestimate Cleveland they are a
legitimate team
we can't Overlook them I think those was
the three most impressive teams uh
throughout week one and I just think we
can't even debated and uh
let's look ahead to week two we're
taking our Aaron Rodgers and the Jets
you know I gotta watch my film tonight
it's Monday Night Football Bills versus
Jets and we get the advantage because we
get an extra day of recovery and they
don't
so guess what guys it's time to start
hunting and start it's starting to start
preparing for the goat uh you would say
in our generation Aaron Rodgers will be
number two behind Tom Brady
as you know if not the best quarterback
right behind him and obviously trying to
surpass Tom but that's almost impossible
at this point in his career but
man oh man Aaron Rodgers the goat
the goat he's the goat and we can't deny
it I'm super excited uh who are you
gonna take bills tonight are we taking
Jess who are we going to take tonight
uh
I don't you know this is a team that
we're not sure who we want to take
because the judge added so much this off
season I just don't know how it's going
to jail they are so they're a highly
talented team too I would see a deep
playoff team that everyone's hoping for
but Josh Allen is just so excited and
every time he's a season opener he does
something uh just ridiculous and we're
just saying oh he's so amazing so my
head is tired I don't know who we have
uh uh I don't know how to Edge it it's
like a 50 50 split because I love both
these quarterbacks I know what they're
capable of and they're just so good they
both have great receivers uh a great
defense uh it's going to be intense uh
and where are Rick Rogers all the time
man Rogers will have to be easily
I think he's a top 10 quarterback off
time all time doesn't matter how you
look about it uh
so it's gonna be exciting to go against
him again he's won it all against me
just like how Brady was hopefully I get
that rematch that Vengeance just like
how I got against Tom uh next week so I
was super excited let's get it can't
wait for you all to be at the home
opener Jets Cowboys and I said it this
year and I said it already this is a
statement year and I've been talking
about why I said that okay
yes I do talk a lot yes I speak highly
I'm very opinionated I talk my trash I
do my junk but I like to back it up and
uh you know when you're a competitor and
you keep coming close you keep edging or
not a little bit you keep getting closer
we took a jump we took a jump and I just
think everyone said nah the Cowboys
can't do it the Cowboys can't do it
Michael Parsons can't do a Dak press I
can't do it we don't have enough we
can't do it it's just like okay take it
all lunch
and we're covering
we're coming
I'm not here no more I'm not first year
Micah no more second year Micah
we're not the first year Cowboys no more
second year Cowboys third year
experienced vet group we coming
I'm looking guys we're coming so y'all
just buckle up get ready it's gonna be a
long journey but I'm gonna see y'all on
top of that mountain and I'm gonna tell
you we're gonna take a lot of people
into that Death Zone see if they can
breathe because not everybody can
breathe the same altitude as you I'm
gonna let y'all know that right now when
people are meant to go some places that
other people can they learn they can't
breathe and they go back down that
mountain
we're going to see if you could breathe
in that Death Zone something to think
about so man tune in to next week
of week two hot takes on the edge your
boy Micah Parts is here thank you for
tuning in it's been great speaking with
you speaking to real I hope everyone
enjoyed it I can't wait for next week
thank you